あ、あん
すいません
あの、昨日の撮影で
風邪を引きました
...
わかってたけどね！！
ちょっと６時間外に出てて
喉がやられたのと
もう身体的にぼろぼろだったんで
クリスマスの日はもう
３時以降すぐ寝たんですけども
寝たきりみたいになっちゃって
クリスマスは寝て、起きて、編集して、終わりました
はじめしゃちょーです！！
久しぶりにちょっと家に帰ってこれたということで
今日はね
ゆるくいきましょう！
.....
かわいい♡
かわいいなぁ
久しぶりに家に着いて
ゆっくりしたいところなんですけれども
ちょっと、とある情報を入れまして
こちらにあるとおもうんですけども
どん兵衛！
どん兵衛！！
みなさんご存じでしょうか
たぶん普通に知ってる人もいるんですけども
年越しといえば！
うぉおえぇぇ！！
うぇっへぇ！
はぁはぁ...
年越しといえば
年越しそばですよね
というわけで
そばとっておこう
今日はこっちだ
うどんで行きます！
どん兵衛！があるんですけども
これあのー
熱湯５分て書いてあります
これはつまり！
どん兵衛は５分温めると一番おいしいタイミングで
召し上がれます！という意味なんですよ
で、これはどん兵衛、日清さんが決めたこと
なんですけども
なんととある情報でですね
お、お、やっぱ出てるわ。
割と情報が入ってるわ
いろんな記事があるんですよ、ネット上で
１０分で食べたほうがおいしいという
話が出ております
日本人ならば誰もが一度は
口にしたことがあるであろう
日清のカップうどん”どん兵衛”
現在ネットではこの”どん兵衛”の
新しい食べ方として
お湯を入れてから通常５分で
食べられるところを
１０分待つことであえて麺を
伸びさせて食べる
”１０分どん兵衛”が話題になっております
ということです
なんかね、いろんな人が１０分で食べたほうが
おいしいって言ってて
麺がつるつるになって
食感が限りなく生の麺に近づく
って話を聞いております
というわけで今日は！！
どん兵衛がこっち２つあるんですけども
５分のほうと１０分のほうで
２つちょっと食べtty比べてみたいと思います
このフードプロフェッサーはじめならね
どっちがおいしいかとか
とかもうちょっとはっきりジャッジメント
しようとおもいます
じゃあちょっとお湯入れてきます
これ純粋に気になるタイプだからね
へぇっくしょん！
ふぇー！ふぇー！ふぇー！ふぇー！
（コンロ点火）
ぐずっ、あー
ぐずっ
...
あのガチで風邪ひいたからね
みんな風邪には気を付けよう
今インフルとか流行ってるからさ
少々お待ちを！！
これガチでうまいんだなたぶん
これたぶんすごいっすよ
なんかいろんな人がつぶやいてたり
なんか言ったりしてるみたいで
ガチでうまいみたいです
やばいなこれなんか
話題になってるから
早くしないと
ほかのYouTuberもやってしまう
俺は急ぐぞ！
早く！早くやんなきゃ
早く！早く！
こーゆーネットで話題の動画は
YouTuberはすぐに動画にしますからね
早めにやっとこう
YouTube見たけどまだ誰もやってません
いやわかんない怖い
待ってほかのYouTuberやってたらどうしよう
ほかのYouTuberやってたら俺は
ほかのYouTuberやってたら...
うわ、たまーにやってる人が...
《今日はみんなでパフェを食べたいと思いまーす》
はーい
あ、かとちゃがやってる
何人かやってるけど
俺はもうこのビックウェーブに乗るしかねえ
まだ、まだ間に合う
まだ間に合うぞ
俺はやりますからね！
先に...
《お湯わいた音》
あぁー！！
ということは先に１０分する方に
入れましょう
いやーはやくはやくはやくスピード！
先に１０分する方にいれますお湯を
５分経った後にこっちに入れて
ちょうど10分経った5分経ったというわけでございます
では入れていきましょう
...あぁー！
今日の夜ご飯だよ
早くしろ
ほかのYouTuberより早く
こっちは10分です
こっちは10分
タイマー！！！！！
タイマータイマータイマー！！
何で普通に入れたの
よしOK
タイマーで10分はかりました
よしこれで満足
で、5分経ったあとにこっちにいれます
...あー！温めなきゃ！！
早く
ぬるかったらちょっと差がでちゃうから
これは引き続き加熱します
はやくはやくはやく
もしもしー
あ、はい
はい
どん兵衛つくっ...
やべぇどん兵衛作ってるから電話してる場合じゃねぇ
よし、あとちょっと
あとちょっとです
10秒前！
......お湯ーーー！！
はい5分たちました
スピードが要だ
はやく
あぁぁぁーーーーー！！！！！
《鼻かんでる》
あ、あ、あ、あん！
もうちょっとでございます
５，４，３，２，１,
きたー！！
はい、というわけで完成しました
こっちが10分どん兵衛
こっちがノーマルなふつうのどん兵衛でございます
これにつゆをいれよう
はやくはやく
よし
はい！できました！
はやくはやくこっからもはやく
はいまずは10分どん兵衛のほうです
ちょっとみていきましょう
やっぱちょっとね、麺が太いんです
ちょっとだけ麺が太い気がします
はい、次！
ノーマル5分待ったどん兵衛です
あ、麺はこっちは普通の太さです
わか、つたわるかなー
お前ら大事なのはここからだ
10分どん兵衛と5分どん兵衛どっちが
おいしいのかっていうのがやっぱり一番大事なので
早速食べてみようと思います
まず10分どん兵衛のほう
うわ、なんかやっぱコシがある
つるつるしてんですよね
いただきます
うん、ちょっと比べてみなきゃわかんない
とりあえずおいしいです
5分のほう
いやー
そーゆーかんじねー
んー！
はいこっちの勝利でございます
あのねぇ
僕はですね食べれればいいみたいな
味音痴なところあるんですけど
ちょっとやっぱり違いが判りました
5分待つとね、どうしてもね、インスタント感がね
のこるんですよ
なんかあまいというか
ちょっとお菓子っぽい感じが残ってて
うん、おいしいんですけど
やっぱどこかこう
なんかお菓子っぽさが残ります
あのね風邪ひいてるときのうどんっておいしいんだよ
まじで
それに対して10分どん兵衛は
水をしっかり吸収していて
なんか麺がつるつるしてるんですよ
なまめんみたいな感じで
なんか、本場の、本場の
うどんみたいな感じがします
なんて真面目なレビューだ
自分でもびっくりするぐらい今日はまじめだわ
でも純粋にね食べてみたかったんすよ
味は結局変わんないんですけども
麺のかんじがかなり変わります
どっちもおいしいから
どっちでもいいとおもう！！！